a violent brawl erupted between in-state  rivals at a college basketball game in  Kansas benches were cleared punches  thrown in the final seconds of the game  between Kansas State and the University  of Kansas last night look at this video  the chaos came after Kay you still be a  de sousa the lot Kansas State's Dewan  Borden shot sending him to the ground at  one point the Sosa was even spotted  swinging a stool there you see it right  there police officers and coaches from  both teams ran to the court to break up  the fight cats got out of control enough  very quickly you know the issues not the  block I think you can see his foot come  into the frame he was kind of warding  over the other player on the ground so  Kansas State's coach Bruce Weber said  it's my guys fault all right he's very  embarrassed  you